greetings from podcast Ville the church
what's happening now is sponsored by the
behind this the irishman podcast you
heard about the film the Irishmen on
Netflix the latest move of Martin
Scorsese starring De Niro Pacino Joe
Pesci and my brother Sebastian is crazy
Joe Gallo I loved all the performances I
like that crazy guy that they played
Tony Pro I mean I thought the movie was
[ __ ] phenomenal I don't care about the
CGI or all these people gives a
freshman's [ __ ] but I will tell you
one thing now you can go behind the
scenes behind the Irishman the official
podcast learn about the real Frank
Sheeran and his deathbed confessions to
killing Jimmy Hoffa learn what drew
DeNiro to the book and how he convinced
Scorsese to make the movie and what it
took them to get Joe Pesci out of
retirement and for the film nerds out
there learn about the D agent technology
they use to make the castle of 20 years
younger it's hosted by Sebastian
Maniscalco who's part of the church
family and he's great in the movie this
is such an epic movie that needed his
own podcast so this is the first Netflix
podcast dedicated to a single film right
now go to behind the Irish when it's
available now on every platform check my
show notes for the links or search for
it now new episodes are for on every
Monday watch the movie then go behind
the scenes with the Irishman the church
is also brought to you by on it listen
they got the alpha brain sweepstakes
he's sitting there on your ass alpha
brain Mexican a great [ __ ] Christmas
present you know somebody was a little
BOTS a little [ __ ] [ __ ] get them
a little out for brains they can start
focusing again right go down it calm the
press in church boom and there you have
it kick this [ __ ] melee just
one of the dirtiest hours you can play
this out and get horny some people this
arm is as dirty as can be they got a
song on here call a lemon song I almost
raped the [ __ ] one night really after I
hurried it when I was 15 I did [ __ ]
angel dust and I drank a bunch of beers
and there was this lady in my block that
a MILF before the milk this 1979 Nobel
in the world of milk show she had big
tits and she'd always wear her would he
call those things in the 70s that was a
no-no I wish that none of the war you
just pulled it over your chest of course
that you pulled it over your chest in
the 70s and you could just pull it down
and show you tits out ah no a two-top
tube tube all the tube top
whatever the foam because we had big
tits yeah you were just huge is my shirt
you just pull the tube top down she had
two dogs they had they were blind
two French poodles that were born you
have to cross him across the street and
they'd [ __ ] in the park when we're
playing basketball and she'd have little
hot pants television flip-flop if I was
14 15 she was 39 Wow 40 and every time
she's over there walk my dog I let the
ball go down the hill it's just like the
walk by her and look at that ass she was
meant a nice everything was meant so I
am but a husband is how hot she was
whenever she wanted don't the husband
would go on about lead or watch to make
sure another was attacked a bunch of
Bandidos Victor he knew right what's
that movie they're [ __ ] how Lord
Josey Wales when they find the blonde
behind the [ __ ] thing and they pull
up by our legs that's when we were 13 oh
my God we're looking to [ __ ] somebody we
just didn't know who the [ __ ] yeah
Iran would accrue that was looking to
[ __ ] we were just looking for the right
like straw dogs but nobody remember that
movie Jesus all those [ __ ] guys
hanging out on the roof it's a rape
scene it's a rape scene but it also
turns into like a [ __ ] weird twisted
love scene then the other guy comes in
for a chew ski
yeah the guy but there was all these
guys hanging out do you remember
Dustin they said them we were savages oh
my god we were ready to go but nobody
knew I was in love with Faye the thing I
was a name Faye and I was going to take
her down and she thought that's bad
one daughter I was friends with the
other daughter dated and ended up
marrying my boob are really tight friend
of mine
so after we'd listened to Led Zeppelin
to win a bunch we did some angel dust
and we drank some beers and everybody's
gonna party how did she dress she was
she always happen coach always showed
the short shorts always short short
short oh he could be [ __ ] thin below
and she'd have a [ __ ] out says she
knew what she was doing oh yes right
nipples would always be hard no one
could oh my god face was gorgeous so one
night I said tonight said I'm taking
that [ __ ] down it was in about two
years at night when she would walk the
dog at 11:00 the husband was older than
her
my cousin was like 60 I'm off you all
for the program
oh she was there for those what a ride
yeah she was that wasn't the girl's
father mom so I went I got some of my
mother's flowers and I went hit by the
bushes own way to [ __ ] they come down
with the two French poodles and when she
put the when she was gonna bend over her
but put the French poodles I was just
gonna attack her and then give her the
flowers who tackles you and gives you
flowers I'm a class act did you give her
the flowers
I walked up behind as I saw so I grabbed
as she turned on she was Coco what a
surprise I brought these for you I had
my best Cologne on I brushed my teeth
Listerine every day I was ready either
from the inside out and I had never even
had sex for a woman before she's like
one of these for one I told how I felt I
love you I want to run away with you
told her that oh everything I told
everything I needed that I had tears in
my eyes I got emotional and she was
that's so sweet
I'm like oh can I kiss you and she told
me that if she ever gets divorce that
she'd consider me just Paul because I'm
such a jerk-off you're 15 what was a
young kid and then I go can I kiss and
she goes absolutely they're like kissed
her on the cheek and then I looked down
I just started staring at a [ __ ] and
she just what's the problem I just
started getting read you know when
you're 14 you're getting warmed up
you're getting random rather and she
goes what's the matter later I just want
to touch your thigh don't say well I
touched like the bottom of a thigh
mm-hmm I like it just feel blood coming
out of my dick everything I had came out
of me I had to run home like Steven
Seagal lamal Steven got all limp up like
he was a half a [ __ ] that
luckly ran home all [ __ ] up oh my god
the nobody and then about four four
years ago me and my Google Bob Bobby
went out for breakfast like I would tell
you time I was gonna [ __ ] rape fake
he goes why why am i hearing about this
now
my it was 1979 I was a young kid I was
on love with Fred because you know if a
lizard me now the only guy he's married
to the thought oh my god oh my god she
look any ghost you know what she walks
around the house all day telling me how
old she is
really he goes maybe gonna hire I'm like
what are you [ __ ] that's 70 something
we giggled we giggled and that was it
and about two weeks later I got a call
one afternoon it's Bobby and I answer
the phone like what's up Bobby goes hold
on something wants to talk to you they
put a on the phone she's like I ain't
knowin sweetie I want you to come visit
me I'm like ah oh my god that's
incredible incredible what's up Nick
alright brother
I feel you did tremendous over the
Yankee playoffs I'm sorry that I didn't
go in your favor but [ __ ] the
Senators were all over the [ __ ] they
were the Nationals were just too strong
for everybody
yeah well the more the New York Post
actually put an article and said why the
Houston Astros were gonna win they even
set people up know everybody had the
Astro story in the World Series nobody
better wash inside no three Pro Ricans
and the polish gotta belt Washington you
know yeah but they had a chance I mean
because every good pitching
Edgar pitchers and in the postseason the
pitching in first two games they they
[ __ ] waxed they waxed the Astros and
then they went back to Washington and it
looked like a different series that look
like okay the Astros are showing their
you know that pedigree they won three on
the road you figured but then I said if
the if the Nationals get it to a seventh
game all bets are off and I just had
this funny feeling I just smelled weird
I've never seen where you know the road
team won every game they run the first
two on the road then they lost that let
the next three at home then they went
back they won that six game I
weird I had and I didn't put my I don't
bet but I had a funny feeling that it
was a possibility and he went to had the
lead in the seventh game and they got to
like three - it was just they had some
mojo going I got rendang they had been
that that kids Soto who was tremendous
for usual it's a [ __ ] baby you see
the swing on this guy tremendous and
then as dry Spergel pitch like a animal
and you know I mean they just was their
time it's good for them you know those
are the old expose men those are
actually a montreal expos what a
Washington Nationals good for them good
for them now you know I mean I'm very
happy for the city yeah listen
Astros I mean the Yankees had a billion
chances they couldn't get the big hit
but after they beat the Yankees it was
like that's that that was that big thing
and like it looked like you know like
they won the World Series they did win
the world says once but I think breeding
the Yankees they the Yankees took a lot
out of them and the Yankees just didn't
they just didn't get a big hit when they
needed it you know they tied that game
in a six game and unbelievable in the
ninth I went crazy in the hotel room
un-fuckin'-believable then Chapman
throws a meatball I don't know why he
would through that [ __ ] pitch to that
Altuve and unbelievable see somebody
made a mean with me yelling at the kids
yeah it was funny that was from me
screaming cuz I couldn't believe he
threw that [ __ ] pitch you don't throw
a no to pitching and he had a silly grin
on his face like what are you [ __ ]
kidding me you're gonna throw that pitch
to that guy come on if you're gonna get
beat get beat with your best don't get
beat with a [ __ ] piece-of-shit pitch
you know that's what bothered me because
LeMay oh he battled battle battled and
tied the game
that guy LeMay yo his tremendous player
oh man well we had fun but we had fun
this year you had fallen that's all this
that's all that matters you know
everybody was you know they all worked
out you got back then I'll shoot law and
all that for you yeah which you were
great on then you have another episode
coming up and I got one more January
night that was a fall finale last
Thursday and then January 9th will be
the second the finale to
at the beginning of the next season good
good show 21 years then what a run they
got man that's a well-oiled machine over
there whoa whoa the only one left right
I guess man I was talking I ste was like
you know his man Nick I came on for four
episodes I wound up doing 20 years ago
20 years crazy
I said yeah look you want ice you know
you know because I know I go man
that's a [ __ ] run that's a run was
right there at Englewood New Jersey he
gets on the ferry yeah cool guy pick him
up on the other side and he goes and
shoots his mother [ __ ] saying what a
[ __ ] life he goes back that's the way
to do it yeah I listen to live in New
York that you have to have John Lennon
money yeah - you're a peep tree people
yeah they're true P pay pay I'm gonna do
what you want I didn't use you know days
[ __ ] free class out freezing out yeah
and I did two scenes of Marishka
Mariska is very good I did one scene
when Ice Cube and dice tingle mortadella
Richard Belzer oh my god I don't know
him you never met him
no I don't know him yes you do I don't
know him yeah I met that [ __ ] Morton
though I met him at the comedy store one
man he was a gentleman and then I see
him on the set of what I've read it's
snowing out in new Europe were shooting
the scene mm-hmm I'm a fat mechanic and
I'm under a car was this which Laura
nota was it that's for you always for
you and dollar an IceCube was supposed
to yeah pull me out and go what were you
what did you see the other night
uh-huh you know and they kept doing it
but the thing kept getting stuck on the
ice right so here I see bells at two
years early at the store the introduces
he watches my set not pop pop funny
great and awesome I go up to him on the
Senate I love you remember me we met
Michael oh it's gonna be like that okay
what did look at you like a like I was a
[ __ ] jerk-off all of a sudden yeah
okay I know what time it is and then he
they're trying to pull me out but they
kept getting stuck on an ice cube and
finally he's like [ __ ] helpless to
you yeah that go I'm trying to get
anything but not all [ __ ] try [ __ ]
doing like a wolf for starters lighten
up [ __ ] an IceCube gotten between us
iced tea and then they got him out of
the sink as I said you know this guy's
confused right this guy's confused he
don't know that I don't give a [ __ ]
about this job I'll punch you in the
[ __ ] mouth he doesn't know who he's
doing
yeah acne skin and the [ __ ] squishy
comedian yeah but he was horrible in
Scarface he was [ __ ] terrible too he
made a living off of being a bad [ __ ]
comic that dude with attitude he got a
bad attitude that day told Nick I never
forgot it but I looked at him after when
I go if you want to throw down I'll
smack that [ __ ] acne off your face
I'm leaving but he left like a [ __ ] that
he is 10 years later so he threw a phone
at somebody at Apple and I go I'm coming
there he lost his mind
why I'm they told him he was good guy
doesn't know how [ __ ] lucky is that
guy gets up every day he's gotta kiss
the floor kiss his sandal throw [ __ ]
hot juice in his face [ __ ]
[ __ ] anyway yeah who gives a [ __ ]
yeah I don't know if they look great
[ __ ] it talk to me what did you think we
all waited and waited and waited what
did you think about the Irishman
tremendous from beginning to end what
did you think well you know the first
time I saw it what did you see I saw it
a little after it came out in the movie
in a movie do I want to see it in now
Westwood okay was in the balcony with my
wife and you know just the first time
you watch something you know you know
you're so excited seeing all these
giants what does the CGI gonna look like
and at the beginning it was a little
weird you know with some of the stuff
with them getting younger and a little
hokey but after a while you just kind of
surrender and and just watch the work
you know but I I thought the movie was a
little slow moving but it didn't bother
me at all because the work was so good
that I you know I wanted to see it again
to see if I liked it as much or I liked
it less but the second time it went
faster alive whether the same theater
and I even liked it better
I even liked it a lot better I think I
think some of the scenes in the movie
are fantastic there's some great great
scenes in the movie the scene between
Joe Pesci and Pacino
a incredible scene that scene is so good
I mean al he's got so much fire for like
a 70 something it's incredible how good
he is still you know and Joe he doesn't
have a false moment in the movie he's
like you watch him and he's just he's
there every second of the movie he's so
good he said people forget how good Joe
Pesci is for John how good go back and
watch Raging Bull and you watch it up
know-it-all like no I'm just saying
watch Lethal Weapon yeah but if you
watch Raging Bull
he's you know Goodfellas casinos are
more flashy Joe Pesci if you watch him
and his great as De Niro is in Raging
Bull
Pesci is as good I mean he's just as
he's right and that's De Niro in his
prime and his [ __ ] prime obviously
and they love each other and you can see
that and then you see that with De Niro
and Pacino that they really enjoy being
together to watch those scenes and
there's there's a real love affair
between the two of them which way you
know you will never would have known
that you would have thought well maybe
those guys would be more competitive
with each other but they're not they're
not at all they they complement each
other I love the scene when he he goes
you know you can't talk to me like that
you called me a [ __ ] and he goes
no not you it doesn't apply to you you
know it wasn't you he goes but I was
standing right there because no I would
never say that to you it was so sweet
you know come on come back in come on
Frank that was really really a terrific
moment there's so many great moments in
the movie I mean you have to you have to
overlook I mean in the perfect world
they should have made this movie 15
years ago they really should have made
the movie when they were younger but it
doesn't you know there are some people
that are not crazy about it there are
some people that I've heard they thought
well it's the same old thing and you
know it was you know I didn't believe
some of the CGI there was a couple of
things I think the voiceover I could
have done but a little less voiceover I
don't think I need it Scorsese stuff but
it's the style that they style that's
what they're doing now they developed
something that works and it really
doesn't bother me that much I mean you
know there are some things I don't need
explain to me but you're right that's
the style that they have what you have
to remember one thing again Nick you're
a student of the 70s you're very lucky
like I'm very lucky we got to see some
of the greatest motion pictures of our
time right having these there's not
Elana can't beat it just 73 alone just
the talent just from from 71 to 73
between the French Connection French
Connection yeah he was a fourth choice
Jeanette will come up fourth choice and
end up winning an Academy Award freaking
director that and he ended up directing
mm-hmm the axis Exorcist you know we've
seen all this great work the problem I
feel today in which I know I feel today
I don't want to sound I never want to
sound like two things in my life yeah
typical New Yorker I've lived here for
23 years there's no bagels get a grip of
me life okay get a grip and number two I
don't want to sound like the old guy
that things were better back then the
problem is we got exposed to something
that was so strong you know I
anticipated waiting for Goodfellas I was
in a halfway house when Goodfellas came
out and I know a year before the movie
got released it was coming out I read
the book I read the [ __ ] book I
thrown into beyond 2020 and I read the
book you know we're living in an age
right now mediocrity yeah movies you go
see a movie you're excited it's a for
you by the time you get to the car you
forgot one with that movies even about
mm-hmm okay you forgotten what it's
about
I've been told about movies that were
great the last two years I've watched
sness said a lot the [ __ ] people dog or
not right they're an okay movie this
movie would do okay and rise heavenly
but would people go home and talk about
it no so we have to when you and I watch
a movie not to mention we grew up these
kids say no no no Jimmy Hoffa is
no they barely know who he was when I
was growing up when I grew up in the 70s
right so you know uh uh there was so
many things that went into this movie
you know you have the internet which
wasn't around when the Godfather was
around so they couldn't I didn't read
any of the reviews I don't really give a
[ __ ] about reviews my ass that's what
they are the only review I care about is
my review and what I get out of pain the
Greg powers for the movie D that's the
only review I give a [ __ ]
in today's world I could watch your
trailer and tell you if that's the movie
you ever watch a trailer you're excited
yeah oh that's the movie you think you
would like to think but sometimes
they're deceiving you're gonna have a
great trailer and not such a great movie
what has happened in today's world is we
don't have we don't have time for great
acting anymore the kids in The Hurt
Locker The Hurt Locker won an Academy
Award for acting he's a great guy he's a
good actor but 20 years ago he could
they wouldn't let him in the [ __ ]
door they can't hurt locker is a great
act yeah what are you talking about Rena
yeah but doesn't he's not macadam a
award actor not by any means at all
these guys there's two or three these
guys that then they're not of they're
not of that caliber we had Laurence
Fishburne we have Denzel Denzel we got
the [ __ ] Mormon the the Scientologist
Cruz Cruz would go there he's worth
every dollar they give he's a movie star
i watch every movie he watches attain we
got my man Pitt we got Leonardo DiCaprio
those guys not watch the more those guys
are quitting town they terrific in the
movies to watch that [ __ ] and nobody's
gonna put Bruce Lee down to me in a
movie so I even refused to watch it on
Jet Blue Men this week that was the
featured movie all right watch the
Irishman I don't want that [ __ ] have you
seen the Irishman on the big screen
no oh you should you should see it on
going I should I should be I'll go watch
it because it deserves a look on the big
i watch it three times that's it huh you
watch it three times watch it to move
the night it came out till 2:00 in the
morning I don't [ __ ] around me I can
respect them too
Michael is deserve okay I watched it
till 2:00 in the morning
I fell asleep obviously I was tired I'm
on the pain pills and the muscle
relaxants for my leg right and then I
watched it on the plane on the way to
Miami that night and then Oh Fort
Lauderdale and then I watched it the
hotel over the weekend because I really
wanted to watch it from a different
perspective I was gonna be up I'm on the
East Coast time when I'm on the road I'm
at least Coast time so I'm not gonna go
to bed till 3:00 anyway now it's it's a
treat to see these guys it's a treat to
see how good they aren't even even like
the Niro's character you know you don't
always appreciate because he kind of
like takes a little bit of a backseat to
Joe and a little bit but yet as the more
you watch him the more you could
appreciate all the little subtleties and
nuances that Bob does because he just
grows on you
De Niro comes on likes he's not as you
know I was a little more you know you
know he's bigger he's bigger he's more
grand and Joe but Bob is like sort of
Bob is an you know he has a part that's
almost because he's playing a couple of
different you know sides in the movie so
but he's really really good too I don't
know she stole my heart this movie Joe
the last time he acted this good was at
the end of Bronx Tale he played the same
characters in the Bronx Tale the end of
Bronx Tale when he goes into he only has
one st. we end in Bronx Tale but the end
of Bronx tell he was it shows his warm
side right in this movie it showed that
he was phenomenal
I don't care about CGI I don't care no
he's great he was phenom he's really
great in it the kid that you mentioned I
thought I watched after you mentioned
that kid Stephen Graham is Germany's
greatest he's from his face he's a he's
a bonafide really good at not know
really good let's get to the two scenes
he had with Al yeah wow he was
phenomenal
those are great scenes phenomenal uh uh
you know is he as your office was in
Union City New Jersey so when I was a
kid Tony Pro yeah the real Tony Pro
heard about me oh he did it that's why
they always said that he was buried at
the Meadowlands mm-hmm that's why they
always said he was
at the Meadowlands behind Tony Pro had
an office in Union City but he also ran
out of mayo whenever you got a white man
at Burger there's a patient Tony Pro so
that's why they always thought he was
buried in giant that was what I wanted
to watch the movie for to see where this
[ __ ] really had the lot did you
read the original I paint houses or no
I'm reading it now that's the book they
just they named it you know the Irishman
it's but it's actually called you know
okay I paint houses red I'm reading it
now and I mean it's pretty much the guys
interviewing a guy and he's telling them
all these stories and you know I've
heard different things some people
saying they feel like some of it is
accurate some of it might not be but you
know listen they told a story from the
book from this guy's perspective do you
believe it
well you don't it's up to you you know I
don't I I mean for me I try to believe
the movie is the movie believable and
knowing seeing what the the guy spent
his life around this guy these guys it
is somewhat believable it is I mean I
don't know if he killed Joe gallo but
Joe gallo was killed I remember because
I was obsessed with crazy Joe I wanted
to make a miniseries out of him there
was a wild movie in the 70s and you
can't even find it it wasn't a great
movie what wasn't there it was a call
crazy Joe crazy but it was Dino De
Laurentiis is to make these like cheap
mafia movies and he made a move you and
the guys great actor but he was kind of
too big to play Joey Gallo was Peter
Boyle but if you remember channel 9 the
million dollar movie they used to play
these movies he made the movie Joe which
was that crazy guy who murdered him and
then he made crazy Joe but Joe was a
really good movie disturbing and if you
remember Joe D they shot all the hippies
in that movie you know the guy was
looking for his daughter Susan Sarandon
have you ever seen Joe know what he's
your Joe is like a guy who's like a
Archie Bunker guy he hates hippies he
hates the states that then he meets this
businessman and he's looking for his
daughter and she's a drug addict
and he's like you know we should go find
a
we should go find them we should shoot
all these [ __ ] hippies all these you
know love child people and and and the
businessman likes this guy he drinks
beer he lives in the you know he's like
one of these like piece of Americana
blue-collar crazy guy was all these
nutty ideas but he actually gets the guy
revved up he's like a businessman they
got shotguns I don't want to give it
away you know and then he goes out and
then they they like start shooting up
like all these druggies none of the
crazy Joe movie now crazy Joe was about
crazy Joe gallo okay and that is made by
Dino De Laurentiis yeah it was here
about in the 70s probably early 70s late
60s wasn't the gang that didn't shoot
straight about Geoghan the gang that
couldn't shoot straight year was
supposedly based on yeah somebody some
of those guys yeah I think it was based
on Jimmy Breslin wrote it and then Jimmy
president was the great columnist of New
York City him and and Pete Hamill but
that was a book that he wrote and
actually De Niro plays a goofy I've
never seen the movie I've never started
her money you can find it but I know
that our boyfriend Jimmy orders Jerry
max in it now Joey Gallo was hanging out
with Jerry Orbach right Joe Gallo
started hanging out with all these movie
stars he started hanging out with a
artists he thought of himself as an
artist too he was like and he was a
really psychopathic guy and then he was
running around with you know all kinds
of people he got out of jail and he was
you know he went against all these guys
you know he was apparently he did the
barbershop murders yeah Anastacia when
those guys got blown away was gallo and
his brothers so they sent the black guy
to shoot what's-his-name the black guy
right the guy's mental health issues
they could never trace him back to Joe
yeah but it's so funny when like who
would have the audacity to shoes on like
that by myself I know Sebastian and also
the Sebastian walks in the room laughs
that's a crazy role I don't know I don't
know if he knows how crazy that guy was
a really psychopathic guy really you
look at him you look at his eyes you
could see how like not
was but the interesting thing was that
he thought he was like you know he
thought he was more of a used to paint
then I'm he had some girlfriend that was
like a one of these like you know
artistic girls so he was running with
that whole crowd but then you know he
just he he stepped on too many toes I
mean him but once you shoot somebody the
boss of the family and I had yeah that's
and they knew exactly who the [ __ ] it
was
they sent like I said I remember reading
up about the black guy had mental health
issues he wasn't he wasn't they couldn't
trace him back to Joe at all right but
when Joe went to prison he hung out with
the brothers in prison so yeah they kind
of had an idea you know I don't even
know if we went down the wint the way it
went down the movie huh I don't know I
don't know I mean I don't even know I
mean they had Frank Sheeran shoot Joey
Gallo and that you know I know he got
blasted and Umberto's cuz my dad used to
love Mafia murders and he was always
like he got blasted when he was eating
spaghetti you know he loved that all
these guys is always wonder we eaten
food some of the Matauri ously got
blasted I thought for me I know somebody
got killed at the clam broth house in
Hoboken but I then I went home and
looked it up I know that Albert crazy
Joe went to the clam broth house in the
Hoboken with Jerry oh yeah but he got
killed on Mulberry Street right yeah I
first you know when I'm watching this
movie at first it's [ __ ] that I heard
growing up right it was little things I
heard growing I never heard of Frank
Sheeran so I never heard of friendship
and I know Tony Pro right Tony Pro I've
heard only pro was when I was a kid my
mother's bookmaking operation was on a
hundred and eighteen between third and
fourth pylon mother get down Porto Rican
with the trains on top right so once a
week we had to go to I never went
they called them Lucy Fabiano's Lucy on
Italiano's they would go pay a Vig over
to Fat Tony right because Fat Tony was
writing me that's Fat Tony Salerno right
right right
in 115 Street was a social club the
Blair mall the Palermo boys club or
something right my sternum being a kid
and walk
across the street mm-hmm they would say
don't walk on that side no sticks a lot
so I would walk across the street and
just walk past and you could smoke
Italian cheese at a deli on the corner
where I'm talking about nineteen
seventies guys yeah you know the last
time I went over there last time I was
118 it was 1980 that's what I used to
run with the Puerto Ricans running
numbers over there but I knew the whole
area was controlled by it told me then
[ __ ] Oh got into it
[ __ ] oh got into it and that's when the
problem started American Gangster
oh he's still talking about the guy in
Holland is he wanted black numbers right
because begin e's had n numbers the
Cubans had la bolita Bonita
that's what it's called the bolita oh no
its numbers it's a paramutual man
Kenny's plane numbers do not oh sure not
as concentrate at the specs because this
fix is to have on the paper right right
right I'm on a piece of paper not even
you walk boom you put six fourteen five
hours money the guy final hours he gives
you a piece of paper he keeps a piece of
paper and upstairs gets a plane
you took my Nicky bought and Nicky
Mickey boss didn't the other one yeah
yeah it wasn't alright Nicky Barnes was
he might have been a jail with Joey
Gallo yeah something sign him one day
because the the first thing that started
all that heroin was the Purple Gang
that's what people don't understand
there's a book called I got it at the
house Felipe gave to me you gotta think
of New York at that time but that way is
wild knew that New York then in the
seventies and Nicky Barnes and the New
York we remember and Joey Gallo I mean
has a crazy crazy time really this is
way before Gotti
this is way before we got his shame in a
bowl this is what was a kid it was
greatly different was [ __ ] completely
different then my mom had a rest dry
cleaning in the Bronx mmm-hmm and that
too was close to a social club I still
remember like the kids in the
neighborhood gone if you go over there
to give you jobs right like pick this
paper up or whatever I never went over
there yeah
but it's so weird to show Fat Tony and
how big of a presence he was in it you
know like I never knew that [ __ ] he
got a pardon from Nixon oh it Hoffa yeah
cuz he gave them money he gave him so
weird how all of them all the Scorsese's
movies connect and I don't mind that no
not a woman tell me what if you watch
Casino
it was the skin from Vegas and they
talked about the Teamsters lending the
money right and Casino so now you get
the other perspective from how Hoffa was
cutting those loans out right what they
didn't tell you in casino they didn't
tell you that right they just told you
you know they mentioned the Teamsters
but they never mentioned you know that
he was you know behind it apart enjoyed
the Irishman
like no you come we had Jordan whatever
here two months ago and he was the guy
from one from Washington for Wall Street
right weird because when I watched Wolf
Wolf of Wall Street I enjoyed it oh it's
enjoyable I could tell already it was a
Scorsese movie yeah and it was being
done a certain way when I saw this I
enjoyed this movie let's get it out of
the way right now if you want to tack me
on line and salmon anyway I don't give a
[ __ ] linear basis I enjoyed it I thought
it was a great movie and the key word
here it was the first time I seen acting
yeah in a long [ __ ] time acting is
becoming a [ __ ] dinosaur over tattoos
and little hats and [ __ ] gold
earrings and you gotta be gay or I got a
higher diversity I got a higher black
for that role it's eating away from
acting that's what I enjoyed about you
know this certain movies you watch it's
got a good plot its got good whatever
but the acting the acting is something
about that acting when I watched what's
love got to do with it and then I
watched king of New York I focus on
Laurence Fishburne he plays two
different types of [ __ ] still
moving out to different types of muling
yeah but you can separate
well you get separate yeah I look at
that it's great to see those kind of
movies again you know what I looked at
what's the baseball movie with Brad Pitt
um Moneyball love that more it's a good
movie I think Brad picture won the
Academy Award a Brad Pitt is an uneasy
he's kind of underrated really under is
it better and he shows it in this I know
you don't want to see the movie but he's
so wonderful in this movement it was
great and Leigh was terrific but Brad
almost steals the movie he actually like
there's something about him in this
movie that you go I like this dude man I
really I've always loved Brad yeah yeah
he's really good at rolling ball
whatever that moving him into the form
yeah he's always been good I love him
he's oh I love them in the Ocean's
eleven movie and like I said he's a
better character actor but because
they've made him a movie star you
sometimes forget he's still a good actor
sometimes they make a guy a movie star
you know I mean like Tom Cruise they
made him a movie star but Tom Cruise is
a good actor he's not just a movie there
are some movie stars that who can't act
he can actually act Tom Cruise and and
Brad Pitt too in my book you know I mean
some guys they're just kind of stars you
know was on the other night I was you
forget how good Brad Pitt is the mood
when he played the NRA with Harrison
Ford was the cop in New York and he got
in trouble while they were shooting that
Brad Pitt trouble for smoke for smoking
[ __ ] pot on the set he kept smoking
reefer net and I'm I know if I know that
was they shot them what's the name of it
it's Brad Pitt and Harrison Ford he
comes from the NRA to come over here to
give messages to people and he comes
over here your messages to people and he
stays with Harrison for losing my PD
blue cop right and then the movie
unfolds I watch the first 20 minutes it
was starting at midnight but I was like
the law look at this this is the double
zone yes okay the devil's own this is I
don't know that one
this isn't Brad Pitt was still you know
fighting for his [ __ ] life and you
could see how short
he was clean even paid jennifer aniston
you know and he's smoking too much to
salutes Jennifer Aniston told him he's
gotta slow down a little bit then mr.
mrs. myth came along he went over there
he sucked that little [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] jammed Elena Joe lost his mind
yeah a little monkey [ __ ] put three
words three little bladders from the
jungle yeah [ __ ] up stay in it yeah
what jennifer aniston still [ __ ]
crying yeah fifty million dollars she's
still crying she's doing all right
she ended up marrying some [ __ ] white
jamoke yeah and now she's a mama look at
all Brett has to do is knock on the door
yeah like that in a [ __ ] eye
everybody knows it in fact he might be
there now yeah I don't know but I'm not
Sean is no [ __ ] world the Brad showed
up and gave a brad dick man 20 years
later it would [ __ ] up but I'll tell you
what I'll also like getting back to the
Irishman is the movie there's it gives
you time to breathe like you said you
can watch the acting and the more you
see it the more you could see scenes
that even like the scene when they're
having cereal at the end that's a great
scene and he's like you know that she's
telling him and he goes you know we did
all we could for this guy cuz I know how
you feel and you know he said you wanna
have some coffee but it's just such a
beautiful scene you're hungry would he
eat in the Eaton's shear I don't know
what they're eating some gold total
though he goes total this this great
little moments between the two of them
sitting there and even like what Alan
Bob's some of the scenes is like you
know I'm worried I'm really worried
about in his life away but he they're
gonna threaten me you know how goes they
wouldn't dare you know they wouldn't
dare he goes I know I'm really you could
feel like he's really concerned you know
but you watched it
there's a beautiful like if you really
appreciate acting you have to see the
movie a couple of times to really see
how rich it is there's such greatness
between not just the big scenes but the
scenes that are subtle beautiful scenes
I mean between Joe and Al and Bob
like Stephen Graham that's what I like I
like that it gives you a chance to you
gotta have an attention span a lot of
people like oh it's slow it's luck it's
not slow that's it's not slow if you're
slow you're slow because you know they
all want fast food and there's Nina this
is a movie that it resonates it stays
with you and what I also liked was you
know that you felt like Jimmy Hoffa was
not one of those guys you didn't feel he
was a gangsta and like people while he
was against I said not necessarily he
did business with them but that doesn't
make him you know he wore white socks
and everything you know and you just I
like that I like that he wasn't just
like one of those guys what I liked the
most was the initial call how you doing
Frank oh that's great things about you
that's tremendous
yeah phone calls yeah the way he went
out of his way this ah Nikesh it's a
little time there he goes I heard you're
a brother of mine yes you're a brother
of mine boy
he goes I love when he says how would
you like the do you want to be a part do
you want to be a part of this history
yes I do
and it was just beautiful it's funny
when petticoats I get that kid here yeah
you almost have to live how you ain't
got that kid here you know I thought
they wasted a little bit because he was
good in the one scene I would have liked
to seen a little more Keitel you know he
was good in the scene when he goes you
know you know about the laundry did you
know when hours goes you know you know
how are you had a good friend a friend
here no you don't know don't know hardly
friendly you know and a real good friend
and and the look on Joe Pesci's faces
like you know he was his rabbi you know
and even when they're you know Pacino's
like well you're with me so they can't
hurt me
you know it definitely there's something
about when you know friendship getting
older aging with those guys that's what
was beautiful about the movie all right
so some of it is you know and when De
Niro throws the guy through the window
that was a little I mean I
whatever you know I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna knock not like the movie because
there's a couple of things that are
hokey some people want to pick on a lot
of [ __ ] it's a beautiful movie it's
worth three hours of your time it is
it's three and a half all right couldn't
would I knock out a half an hour maybe
maybe I could have shortened it a little
bit but it's worth your time it's worth
seeing it on the big screen see it on
the big screen
then you're watching on Netflix like I
did that's what you do go have the
experience in a movie theater you know I
saw a Godfather 1 & 2 a double feature
with my dad back to back how'd you like
to sit there for seven hours it's gotta
be good better than good a terrific me
Nick I gotta be honest yeah I don't have
three and a half in a daytime no I
understand me I always know there's
going to be the plane when I saw I was
coming up to 27th that's why I booked
Miami and I took a red-eye yeah because
for me I knew it was gonna be the plane
I'm the type of guy yeah I could sit
here all week nobody calls the minute I
sit in the movie all some Pacino wants
to see me for the biggest role in my
life and now you look at the email and
you look at the phone and you put it
away but now as you're watching you
can't say right I can't go to the movies
for three and a half hours cuz I can't
think I can't sit there I can't sit down
I wish I could anymore I wish I had the
[ __ ] well this was one I want to do I
don't really like if I'm on the road and
somebody has on Friday had a matinee
especially now I love that the way they
are I'll go I told him two o'clock
yeah I would go to a nice rustic Peter
got a nice lunch a Chinese restaurant I
grow fried rice shrimp and lobster sauce
smoked two joints and go and sit down
and take another book cuz I'm not going
over for three and a half hours yeah
that's what I would do and that's the
way that this I did Friday night that's
right on the plane but it's a treat to
see it on the big Oliver's because the
performance is a these guys are so good
you want to see them you know I even my
brother saw that we went to the New York
opening and he liked it a lot and he
said I want to see it again I knew I
said I watched it the beginning of it
Wednesday night I stood up till about
2:00
I didn't get up to Sebastian I know that
I'm gonna participate now you didn't get
up then but what I had seen I liked
already bright so I was like perfect now
I guess he had a nice moment with the
Niro funny yeah you know it was I was
very happy for him
just when I'm talking I was very happy
for much I'm sure was very exciting from
ahead of me I mean you see some of these
comedians in a movie I mean Ray Romano
he's been doing a little more acting and
they given him even him uh you know it
was great this is you know he's growing
these guys are improving
they're improving our boy was good the
Cuban kind of volley the course Bob was
good yeah with you know well Bobby you
always got to give the Cuban cutting the
chicken right there that's the letter I
would write I like when he's low yeah
well he wants takers I do I can get you
steak yeah I like steak yeah Bobby's
very funny he's very funny and you know
he was tremendous in a boardwalk didn't
ever seen him in tremendous my Bobby's
got a lot of talent he's Cuban anytime
he's got some Italian mmm I don't know I
didn't see I didn't know a lot of the
story beforehand so something that I
kind of wished I could see this even
more like I would like this more I think
it was like a short mini series on
Netflix like four or five hours you know
Lee you might not be completely wrong it
probably could have been a well served
because now when they're doing these six
part these eight part like John side of
yeah it almost that's not that's a great
idea
but I don't think these guys would have
went that route because I don't have
those guys it's a lot of time with them
yeah but it's a I think it's a little
it's not that's a slow movie it's that
at like the seventies movies back then
we're long for movies then and now if
it's anything over
any minutes people now they get tired
yeah so if I could have seen like had a
little bit more explanation about Hoffa
like I thought they did a good job there
like he was like the Beatles he was like
Elvis
but like have a little bit more with him
and have a little bit maybe more with De
Niro's kids yeah cuz they didn't let
that talk much it was more like I think
it woulda been like four or five hours
like split up by hour that I would have
missed a problem okay any good doer
though another problem we have in
today's society of moviemaking in
television is that we don't have a good
directors we do not have good directors
we have people who know how to shoot a
camera right nobody went to directing
school nobody to learn nobody studied
the underlying message throughout the
movie was with the daughter knew what
was going on the whole time that was
unspoken that was on spur right okay and
wasn't said by like that you did like
that I like that yeah I didn't in my
imagination yeah what we don't have
today if it's not spelled I guarantee if
I made a four-hour [ __ ] worry about
iron man all these little [ __ ]
wouldn't say there was no paying
attention if I made a four-hour boy
about iron man [ __ ] Silver Surfer and
all this little white [ __ ] they're doing
now mm-hmm nobody would make a complaint
nobody would have a book The Avengers
four hours yeah 5 hours not one person
would say book right you know we these
are different mentalities yeah this
guy's been making this guy started out
making you know we we should him in the
[ __ ] mean Street yeah and we've seen
him evolve over the years so it's 40
years of really being a real Doris an
accumulation a body aberration right so
it's being a real director what we have
today you know you want to see John with
two or three did you not know okay did
you see John wick - no did you see John
wick what no what are we gonna see any
John wick movie while you're there
you're very entertained while you walk
back to the car quiz your wife and ask
was the movie about you remember it you
don't remember I'm saying there's no you
don't remember that's the whole thing
for there is nothing does it stay with
you when I watch a movie today I walk in
I walk out and I go home it's a cute
movie yeah never think about it again
you never think about the urge you're
putting it on this movie I knew I was
gonna watch it again yeah I mean like I
said I watched an hour and a half of it
after six edibles 22 bong hits you got a
figure eight muscle relaxants in the
pain pill because my mic is [ __ ] up so
but I couldn't really grasp it so what I
knew I was gonna watch it again
people yell people gonna complain about
everything in this world me I don't
really give a [ __ ]
I don't read Yelp I've never given a
[ __ ] when anybody else has said I got
three people three or four people they
tell me to go to a restaurant that if
they don't tell me to go to that
restaurant I'll lower you talking if you
don't know what you're looking at right
that's a problem I mean sometimes you
got to tell somebody and and they still
don't get it you know that was a great
scene and the guy goes yeah but they
really don't know what they're looking
at they really don't understand what the
[ __ ] that is sometimes people just don't
know this is like a baseball game you
can watch it and then you know how to if
you watch it with me I can show you how
to watch it through my eyes it's a
little different and it's just like
watching good acting you can see it well
this is what I got and that's why it's
such a treat to see those kind of guys
that you know there's nobody left at it
last last of the Mohicans you're never
gonna see them probably again like this
probably not you know you know I mean
Joe is probably go back to playing golf
he's tremendous but we haven't seen Joe
forever and I will probably continue to
do his thing and Bob does a little bit
of both but this was really a passion
project for Bob to get back to where he
came from serious acting real acting you
know Tom had
I'm happy this move and then I gotta be
honest for you two weeks ago I was at
the improv
I had gotten off stage I sat down there
was me Rogan and Tony inch cliff and
Rogan asked me if I was excited about
the Irish when I told him no you said no
no was he excited Rossio side did he see
it I don't know okay I told him he's a
novel he ain't got no three and a half
hours
we ain't got three and a half hours
three and a half hours is a plane or at
night so it's a bit much for people yeah
I know he'll watch on a plane or I'm at
listen after he died in the movie you
could have wrapped it up then I mean it
went on a little bit at the end what but
no boy cuz I liked what you said earlier
it watched him grow that line when he
goes we goin going to church you'll see
that's a great line ya know the same law
and then to see them interview him at
the end and they tell him that nobody's
left nobody's left from that day what
are you hiding it must just right
there's nobody there's nobody left we
know yeah this guy everybody's dead and
they're so fat good the other thing I
liked about this movie is that for the
last 30 years if you're a mafia
enthusiast or you like those type of
movies you've always heard of the five
families the Colombo's the Genovese is
the Gambino's the bonanno's and the
mobile solenoids right the Lucchese and
then you got that other thing over in
New Jersey which is Sam the plumber or
whatever years ago there was a script
going around about around about water
something Pennsylvania there was a
script called around really good script
mm-hmm about hijacking and the [ __ ] that
was gonna that's whether we're cutting
the heroin and his brand into the city
and they had their own family up there
right you know and I know where Mike
Kessler lives today the wolf man they
gotta used to come on the show there's
still dabs of
little mafia pockets up there he tells
me that there's somebody that's still
alive up there really really like 80-78
he's still alive he's out of jail
he told me his name recently but it's so
weird like how the Buffalo was the
Magaddino crime family mm-hm you know
that's where [ __ ] went after he killed
Michael after he killed Michael's wife
in the Godfather
he went to Buffalo that's why if you
watch the long hair version of the
Godfather he blows up the pizza place
alright you mean yeah the grease balls
right so we have the two careful we are
not forward yeah Africa Paulo and yeah
the other guy it's really weird to show
people that Russ whatever his name is
McGee whatever you want to call he was
in charge of a small Italian family out
of Pennsylvania mm-hmm he worked at
[ __ ] Canada Dry as a mechanic and he
knew everything about cars and trucks
and all that well that's how we knew all
that stuff that's how he knew all that
stuff in real life he had worked for
ginger ale I know this glass to the
podcast today the sebastien podcast oh
they explained that on this yeah that'll
decay doing with this podcast
oh they're explaining a lot of details a
lot of details to to accompany you you
know to let you know what the [ __ ] is
going on so that's good to know because
you know like like Lee said they they
kind of skim the surface on some things
like even Jimmy Hoffa he was such an
interesting guy but she knows tremendous
in a movie but but maybe like to see in
just a little you know know a little
more about him because you see the
interviews of the real Jimmy Hoffa it's
an interesting dude smart guy all right
now now I'm gonna revisit go on YouTube
you see these interview now I'm gonna
revisit half of the movie the one that
came out 20 years ago with Jack
Nicholson and now Jack is very good in
him yeah
Jack Jack does it different or different
like different completely not as always
not as good a movie the veto is but Jack
is great Jack is great al is great but
it did different I don't want to compare
and you know I mean Al's got some scenes
in the movie that are like you know
Academy Award scenes
the two scenes with Tony Pro and the
scene with Joe Pesci just those three
scenes knock you the [ __ ] out if you
want to be an actor you watch those
scenes you go wow he's got scenes that I
like show-stopping scenes you know but
but Jack is tremendous you know as Jimmy
Hoffa there's an old movie that Stallone
did not a bad movie and it's based on
Jimmy Hoffa it's called fist fist yes
and it's very much based on and sly
plays uh he plays this guy John Kovac
but really John Kovac was the head of
the Teamsters it was really was really
playing Jimmy Hoffa
Tony LoBianco plays a mob guy young Tony
lobia who was a good actor he was in the
7-ups French Connection Tony lo was like
a really good character yes the the
luncheonette yeah at lunch today the guy
was a really good New York actor there
guys like ham Tony moose auntie who was
another great actor who was toma the TV
show before beretta but Tony Mazzanti
was in Pope of Greenwich Village he's
he's the uncle he's gay kisses him by
the game he's a great act that I guy
Tony Muser
but Tony lo was was good and Stallone
was really good in this movie fist he
it's worth watching he didn't get like
he got you know a lot of people try to
knock him but he was actually he's
really good in that movie I really loved
that movie
fist have you ever seen it it's been 20
years it's like to an effect the Lords
of Flatbush man yes
when do I eat I'm saying like like
anybody that hasn't seen the Lords of
Flatbush yeah you're missing out I have
been making a list of movies to watch
he's so good in the Lords of Flatbush it
ain't funny how good he is in the movie
there is a list that I've been making to
watch you've seen the Lord slab right
God I see the movie Peter Wright and me
go with you
may 12 over data and the beauty of this
is that I've been making a list of
movies I want to watch
I tell people like movies that guys at
the back of mine yeah you gotta have you
seen fingers yes that's Lenny cartel
havock a terracotta yes tremendous been
my goofy Gazzo this has been 20 i got a
six-year-old yeah I know it's hard I put
the [ __ ] on TV it's hard you you sit
alone at the house you put the [ __ ]
Muslim time to watch a movie in him this
not saying [ __ ] I'm suck she's in the
other room I can't yeah you can't so
whatever I watch I gotta watch I get
that little girl I got a spot I call me
at night you know you know the movie
thing it's like we have a friend Rick
Ramos weather a tremendous movie podcast
Rick I'll stay up all [ __ ] night
mastered and thought the movies yeah
like last night one of my favorite
movies was on this [ __ ] movie I can't
ever get enough of it the town oh it's
one of my favorite kill why'd she how
was it was he in that movie better
phenomenal phenomenal [ __ ] it's on TV
it's like a ratty empty it's on it's on
HBO right now so like pick it up I'll
pick it up in the middle or the end I
just love the movie I just can't get a
look I never tire of they love it love
everybody's not only yet detaining it's
really good really really good really
really I see the chubby guy all the time
who's the chunky wreckfish that eat okay
I go there with my wife I condors oh
that's a good movie he's over there
eat over I've eaten stuff that's how you
drive a [ __ ] car how's the podcast
couples going great it's going great I'm
gonna come down yeah come down someday
maybe we'll we if you want to go we'll
do it in a restaurant or something is
closer for you yeah everybody wants you
to come on yeah Joey today we're gonna
order that pizza because I'm hearing
that it's better why don't we do we will
do so let's just do something live for
me yeah live from over there who had the
I have the Sicilian of some [ __ ] a
couple of weeks let me know well do they
know what I thought about this movie I
wanted to talk about it was either you
were wriggling or no once I saw you
yelling Wednesday night you said
something Rappaport on periscope
I'm like well they were dropping at
midnight yeah so I Whaley attend them in
that I go or maybe it's at 9:00 I saw it
twice already
now I may go see it again this week
really well cuz I'm a movie
well because my fault laws in town and I
figure you know like the guy to see it
on the big screen you know I mean where
is it now is it it's at the Laemmle
there was one here in NoHo and there's
one Laemmle in Encino so so that it's
playable um we have no home yeah I think
so
it is yeah I hope you get to see it on
the big ya know it's like come on you
know indict yeah she goes to brother
they dirty if they have a [ __ ] nine
o'clock showing I might as well go get
nice and I why not have you seen inland
big screen now the big screen now bring
a [ __ ] bring a [ __ ] don't take the
phone with me theater that's like a
focus at night right like lately what I
do is I love [ __ ] them and they go to
bed at night yeah sure that's your time
out it them listen my wife knows that
[ __ ] rule I shoot in my office I
start right and I write straight till
eleven o'clock cosines Anika come to do
I take a breather I only write jokes
Anika yeah right now book book well man
show whatever the [ __ ] I'm watching what
I'm doing I'm right right so that's what
like I said three hours in a while now I
want to see after you see it on the big
screen just to see your your reaction I
mean I think you're gonna like it even
more because you know cuz this is always
a little bit of a letdown yet there are
some movies that hold up it looks
beautiful on you know on the TV - it
does look beautiful but it's a movie
it's not it's not it you know I think
would actually be better on the big
screen just because like I took a break
like two hours and like you check your
phone a little bit you go to the
bathroom on the in the movie theater
you're forced to really pay attention
yeah and that's what you know I got a
plane you have to pay attention you do
for me on a plane there's no phone
there's no guys that's what I want to
watch a movie I just wait and watch on a
plane really I get a mint seat I sit by
myself i foot put the earphones on and i
[ __ ] watch and I relax I said oh I
could do it because once I'm gonna find
if I go to a matinee the phones might
start right man trust soon as I get said
Monday to Thursday now one [ __ ]
personal call I go to this movie
appearing with the sea Rambo mean way
throughout the [ __ ]
we you know the phone starts ringing I
don't care it's Friday that you can't do
nothing me out of mind we're gonna do an
audition tomorrow
so I just waited but daytime movie woman
I was I was my when they I grew up in a
movie theater yeah you know when you
watch this movie brought me back well
cuz go out to the movies was special
that we went as a family we went when we
went it wasn't a daily occurrence no it
was an event it was like flying there
was a time when flying you put a suit on
right you [ __ ] what big deal had big
deal my you fly you feel like a [ __ ]
pilot these people wash dirty feet yeah
flip-flops
[ __ ] up I got no class a [ __ ] dogs
on the floor plane animals that dog [ __ ]
they have to pull the [ __ ] plane down
I'm just happy to hear about that
yeah oh no I know what happens I'll
[ __ ] kill you I'll [ __ ] kill you
on the way la poisonous [ __ ] I'm like
Michael Vick was like a [ __ ] at altar
boy I'll [ __ ] shoot it with a dart I
don't give a [ __ ]
I will electrocute that [ __ ] dog with
my hearing aid I'll put the hearing aid
on them and throw water on that mother
I'll [ __ ] that [ __ ] up what's
the name of the podcast break and break
when does it get it released it releases
usually on Thursday we're gonna have
John Salley in this week ok good he's a
good man so we should have the fly and
you first
get the phone alright bring you have
some pizza with you number one the
Churchill what's happened now is brought
to you by the church today was sponsored
by the behind the scene Irishmen podcast
I mean we've just discussed the Irishmen
for the last hour and a half its latest
movie by Martin Scorsese stars De Niro
Pacino Joe Pesci and my brother
Sebastian as crazy Joe Gallo
listen like Nikolai said the movie was
fine Memphis I didn't care about the
length of it it was the beauty of it the
acting of it and everything else that I
had to do with it but like Lee said that
there was parts you didn't know about
you never heard about it now you can go
behind the scenes with behind the
irishman the official podcast learn
about the real Frank Sheeran and his
deathbed confessions to killing Jimmy
Hoffa learn what drew De Niro to the
book and how he convinced Scorsese
to make the move it
approximately nine years ago yeah it's
more than yeah and what it took them to
get Joe Pesci out of retirement and for
the film nerds out there learn about the
D aging technology they used to make the
cast look 20 years younger it's hosted
by my brother MTV Award tremendous comic
Sebastian Maniscalco who's part of the
church family and he's great in the
movie himself is Joey Gallo this is such
an epic film it needed its own podcast
this is the first Netflix podcast
dedicated to a single film now do me a
favor right now I don't know if you
watch the movie and not watch the movie
but go to behind the Irishman it's
available now on every platform that
means app will Spotify stuff like that
check my shell notes for the link or
search it
search for it now new episodes come down
every Monday make sure you listen to
today's it's gonna clarify the movie a
lot and hope y'all watch the movie then
go behind the Irishmen I want to thank
them behind the Irishman podcast I want
to thank my boogie thought AG but most
importantly I want to thank you bad
[ __ ] for always supporting us
don't forget I think the six tickets
left for the Late Show at the town hall
at forty two hours and there's like nine
left
at nine hundred and you paid bow over
[ __ ] 35 you a jerk-off the second show
is gonna be good so be worth forty two
hours but don't pay over [ __ ] that at
all for nothing of my shows the night
allows you could get a plaint they come
down I go to a comedy store and see you
all of us perform so I got collusive
casino December 27th and the San
Francisco Performing Arts Theatre on the
28th and without that that's it and
that's that I'm gonna thank makeup
tutorial for stopping in and covering
the irishman what's the name of the book
the Irishman the Irishman so you paint
houses but the real title is you paint
houses you paint houses so if you're
into the movie if you enjoyed it thank
you very much listen today we'll be back
Wednesday morning tip-top [ __ ]
Magoo ready to [ __ ] go write a little
Tony benefit
and the damn right I love you
[ __ ] see you Wednesday morning
have a great week
stay black kick this [ __ ] me only